we have had in the last 24 hours an
absolutely unhinged unrestricted
unfettered rampaging Donald Trump who
has threatened to obliterate the Turkish
economy we have the tweets why is Trump
talking about obliterating a country a
country's economy that he can't even
find on a map because it all relates to
pulling American troops from Syria and
I'll explain and we will have a
discussion about it a Donald Trump once
again has brought up this issue of
pulling troops from Syria he's been
talking about this for some time now and
Donald Trump made the announcement that
he is pulling back troops from the north
of Syria and allowing Turkey to do a
military offensive in the area now there
are even supporters of Donald Trump's
that are saying this makes no damn sense
this includes a Republican presidential
brown-noser Lindsey Graham this includes
Brian Kilmeade on Fox News we'll get to
that a little bit later but Donald Trump
took to Twitter and said don't worry if
turkey does anything I don't like I will
destroy their economy nice right even
crazier is that in threatening to
obliterate their economy Trump patted
himself on the back for being a genius
and also referenced previously
destroying economies I don't even know
that I understand what he says here
let's take a look
quote as I have stated strongly before
and just to reiterate if turkey does
anything that I in my great and
unmatched wisdom this is someone with a
deep deep deep problem consider to be
off-limits I will totally destroy and
obliterate the economy of Turkey I've
done before they must with Europe and
others watch over the captured Isis
fighters and Families the US has fought
done far more than anyone could have
expected including the capture of 100%
of the Isis Caliphate it is time now for
others in the region some of great
wealth to protect their own territory
the USA is great incredible stability
evidenced by these tweets right I will
totally destroy and obliterate the
economy
of Turkey also what does he mean I've
done before does he mean he's previously
destroyed Turkey's economy does he mean
he's previously threatened to destroy
turkeys economy does he mean that he's
previously destroyed other economies I
don't know what he means and this is not
merely just more Trump insanity there
are not only really important policy
things to discuss with this entire Syria
thing within hours of Donald Trump doing
this turkey has already attacked Kurdish
positions in northern Syria which we'll
talk about in a little bit
Trump originally said we're getting out
of Syria and you had rightist say that
that's good because they just like
anything that Donald Trump says you had
some rightists say it's bad because they
are wanting more troops in as many
places as possible you had some leftists
a good anytime Trump wants troops out
somewhere we should support it but the
real analysis required more nuance we
are against as progressives we are
against pointless counterproductive
indefinite sometimes illegal military
engagements no question no argument from
me in the big picture we want troops out
of Syria but when Trump does it with
seemingly no strategic imperative or
timing or common sense we should be
concerned about why it's happening what
was the strategic reason to pull troops
unilaterally when Trump said he was
going to do it I don't even know if it
was months or a year ago at this point
in time we never found one although
there were significant sort of motive
elements that we could find that related
to Russia and they related to Turkey and
they possibly related to Trump's
business dealings in Turkey could relate
to khashoggi now I mean we'll talk about
that and now the reason for this
particular pullback is to let Turkey run
an operation which Trump is already
threatening to destroy their economy
over if he doesn't like how it goes does
anybody else see how bipolar and
ridiculous and nonsensical this is and
I was going to tell you at this point in
the story we will see what the next shoe
to drop is we actually know what it is
within hours of this announcement turkey
struck Kurdish targets in northern Syria
and we're going to discuss that next and
if you're counting on Trump's stable
genius to figure out or to try to even
parse this in any way for you good luck